in the fuzzy friendly world of political
correctness you know and I do it myself
because you can't always be a warrior
and that sometimes you know late in the
day somebody will say something to me
that I just and I just say yeah face on
Mars or whatever it is and I still have
the strength to lash out anymore but III
think that you're very right very part
of of the antidote to informational
overwhelming to social islanding to
trivialization is rational discourse
conducted if necessary at high volume
people are so concerned that nobody feel
hurt or rejected or you know will in
intellectual discourse you don't want
people to feel hurt you want them to
feel destroyed if their position merits
that we're all grown-ups we don't have
to coddle each other for crying out loud
send the inner child down to the baths
and sharpen your rhetorical knives and
logical razors and do that kid a favor
make sense out of your life and reality
there's sense to be made and it's very
grown-up and very exalting and it
doesn't have to exclude all the other
fun and games of life but it certainly
gives cogent see and meaning to the
enterprise not only of trying to live
and not only of trying to be a decent
person for one's loved ones and children
but to build a better world a better
world if it comes will be built on clear
thinking
it will be built on honesty it will be
built on direct clear communication I
mean the these are the things that
constitute the visionary common sense
and it's because the world is
topsy-turvy that I considered you know a
drug-crazed pariah and have to then
become the apostle of order dignity
adult behavior responsibility and the
obligation to make